bei uns im studio begrüßen wir jetzt den
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach von der spd schon guten
morgen herzlich willkommen gut morgen
wir sprechen gleich über diese neuen
änderungen und auch den blick auf den
herbst möchten aber zunächst noch einmal
die aktuellen zahlen einblenden denn die
bundesweite sieben tage incidents liegt
laut lka heute bei rund
669 vor einem jahr im vergleich lag sie
noch bei etwa 5 und auf den
intensivstationen werden 934 menschen
wegen coop 19 aktuell behandelt vor
einem jahr meldete dass die wir intensiv
register
664 patientinnen und patienten also eher
lauterbach wir sehen die pandemie ist ja
alles andere als vorbei aber zur
wahrheit gehört auch die datenlage ist
weiterhin ein großes problem
die zahlen liefern eben kein genaues
bild der pandemie ist es also nicht am
falschen ende gespart ausgerechnet beim
testen zu kürzen weil die folge von
ungenau daten könnte eine weitere
ausbreitung seien weitere maßnahmen
weitere kosten also man muss das trennen
die daten sind nicht tagesaktuell genau
und das wird ja gerade geändert wir
arbeiten gerade an einem gesetz
sicherstellen soll dass wir ab dem
september die daten wie viele menschen
sind in den krankenhäusern für profit
während er behandelt wie viele freie
betten haben wir also das elektronische
und jeden tag bekommen das wird geändert
das ist auch notwendig das hat viel zu
lange gedauert haben wir aber jetzt wo
also gesetzlich vor das gehört zu den
maßnahmen die wir für den herbst
vorbereiten die notwendig sind und bei
den tests ist es so die tests sind wer
vor die sind wichtig ich hätte sie gerne
weiter komplett kostenlos angeboten das
konnten wir uns aber nicht mehr leisten
ich hab das ja mit dem
bundesfinanzminister verhandelt und die
ausgaben lagen ja zum teil bei einer
milliarde pro monat und dafür sind wir
jetzt mit dem schweren herbst der vor
uns liegt wirtschaftlich in der lage da
haben wir das ein geschenk auf
diejenigen die es benötigen werden auch
missbrauch einschränken aber dann sind
die tests weiter da es gab ja auch
stimmen die test ganz abzuschaffen weil
sie den missbrauch einschränken die
kranke oma die man offenbar besuchte
kann jeder vortäuschen na ja zunächst
einmal man ist immer auf die ehrlichkeit
der bürger angewiesen aber derjenige der
den test wilde unterschreibt das ja und
werden beispielsweise
die großmutter in der pflegeeinrichtung
ist dann braucht man von der
pflegeeinrichtung ein formblatt was
unterschieden ist das muss hinterlegt
werden somit es gibt immer die
möglichkeit des betrugs aber ich sag mal
so im vergleich zu dem betrug denen wir
gehabt haben die ist diese region besser
weil man muss zumindest etwas
dokumentieren das wird also das wird
quasi gesammelt und dann kann man proben
machen und derjenige der betrogen hat
der macht sich ja auch strafbar das
bedeutet natürlich wenn ich das höre
auch einen enormen bürokratischen
aufwand also ganz so einfach wird das
mit sicherheit in der praxis dann auch
nicht sein da der aufwand ist
überschaubar man dokumentiert auf einem
formblatt was man aus dem netz herunter
dann kann das caritas-zentrum machen
dass man diese kriterien erfüllt und das
unterschreibt man somit wäre es
gezielter betrug wenn man lügt er
lauterbach morgen gibt es ein bericht
vom sachverständigenrat was erhoffen sie
sich davon welche maßnahmen sie daraus
ableiten können jetzt für den herbst
also das ist ein puzzlestück in einem
großen puzzle wir haben auch andere
experten räte zum beispiel ein
expertenrat der die das ministerium das
kanzleramt regelmäßig berät tag der fast
wöchentlich von dort bekommen wir viele
informationen die internationale
literatur wird immer besser wir beraten
uns auch international somit ist das ein
weiterer baustein das ist nicht nur
interessant darauf wird es auch lange
gewartet aber das ist jetzt nicht die
blaupause dafür was im herbst machen
sondern ein baustein von vielen ok und
bisher haben sie sich auf welche
maßnahmen schon gedanklich vorbereitet
also wir haben ich habe diese sieben
punkte programm vorgelegt was auch von
der gesundheitsministerkonferenz sehr
wohlwollend angenommen worden ist da
sind sechs punkte werden die sind jetzt
von diesem gesetz infektionsschutzgesetz
unabhängig sondern die kann man auch so
machen daran arbeiten wir schon dazu
zählen die also bürger test test
verordnung dazu zählt dass wir eine
impfkampagne vorbereiten ich rechne mit
den impfstoffen doch jetzt etwas später
als also zu hoffen gewesen ist ergibt
sinn
im herbst genau das könnte sich
tatsächlich noch verschieben auch in den
späteren herbst und daher muss brauchen
wir eine gute impfkampagne mit den
impfstoffen auch die wir haben dass es
weitergeht über den sommer brauchen ganz
dringend eine bessere verwendung der
arzneimittel waren ganz tolle
arzneimittel die wirkung bei den
lizenzumsätzen sie zu wenig ein jetzt
habe ich vor zwei wochen mit klaus stöhr
einem mitglied des sachverständigenrates
gesprochen und er hat zu uns gesagt wer
jetzt nach masken ruft nimmt menschen
die gelegenheit sich langfristig mit dem
virus zu arrangieren denn erst die
kombination also aus impfung klos
infektion bringt langen sicheren schutz
stimmt das das ist auf jeden fall eine
außenseiterposition also sie in unseren
experten rat also der osterwoche bald
wird diese position nicht vorgetragen
und ich lese sie auch nicht in der
internationalen literatur aber es ist
auf jeden fall so dass wir alles
mitnehmen also ich nehme jede position
mit das wäre jetzt eine position die man
nicht so oft hört das ist aber jeder
kann hier der wissenschaftler sich
einbringen dafür ist das ja eine plurale
gesellschaft da setze ich nachher das
durch was von den meisten für richtig
gehalten wird dann zum schluss herr
lauterbach noch ein anderes thema sie
wollen den zusatzbeitrag für die
gesetzliche krankenversicherung um 0,3
punkte auf 1,6 prozent anheben dann gibt
es breite kritik aus vielen
verschiedenen richtungen daran dass sich
dass geringverdiener und rentner vor
allen dingen nicht leisten können dass
in diesen schwierigen zeiten die
rechtfertigen sie das ich habe ein
defizit geerbt von 17 milliarden euro
das muss ja irgendwie gedeckt werden das
löst sich nicht in luft auf und dieses
defizit also habe ich versucht so zu
decken das reserven mobilisiert werden
dass der steuerzuschuss selbst steigt
aber es ging nicht ganz ohne dass der
beitragssatz steigt das hat mir sehr
wehgetan leid getan aber an dass es
nicht möglich sonst hätten wir
leistungen kürzen müssen und das möchte
ich einfach nicht ich möchte nicht in
einer situation die jetzt wieder
menschen sowieso knapp bei kasse sind
dass ausgerechnet diejenigen die krank
sind
das bezahlen denn jede leistungskürzung
wird es nur von den kranken bezahlt das
kann nicht richtig sagen jetzt in dieser
zeit passt das nicht
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach war das bei uns im studio
vielen dank für das interview